yeah all right earlier this week the New
York Times published a help-wanted ad a
staffer actually tweeted this folks the
New York Times
needs your help we're looking for false
information being spread deliberately to
confuse mislead or influence voters
ahead of the 2018 midterms tip line here
please
share I love the folks parts that so
will think they're actually human now
when I first heard the Times asking for
proof of fake news I sent them a New
York Times gift subscription I mean
really I mean think about it
The Times asking for proof of fake news
that's like Dolly Parton setting up a
GoFundMe page for breast implants or
Michael Moore pleading for more cake or
maroon 5 asking you to write more
terrible songs
yeah and room 5 as if the NFL isn't
screwed enough they hired a car alarm to
play at the Super Bowl
I think we found something worse than
kneeling before the flag its puking in
your ear
[Music]
not by you
chocolate talked about a dog whistle
every time that's played an angel sets
itself on fire anyway here's some fake
news okay
you know that little box on your front
page that says all the news that's fit
to print that's fake every time the real
story is not fit to print like the good
news coming out of the Koreas no nukes
is good news so the times can't be
bothered did you hear about our dealings
with Poland if it undermines the Russian
collusion narrative you're not gonna
hear much and there's that endless good
news on the economy but who's counting
just people seeing more cash in their
wallets but that's not what the Times
wants you to see no they want fake news
from readers just to camouflage their
conveyor belt of bias and they can't do
it without you or a hand mirror by the
way I'm not saying I don't make mistakes
this is actually what I wore at the
Emmys very very angry at my stylist but
I make mistakes every time I open my
mouth that's not fake news though The
Times misleads by design and they only
admit the big errors when they're
actually cornered remember this headline
Nikki Haley's view of New York is
priceless her curtains 50 2701 dollars
sounds like they're blaming her for the
purchase because they are even though
near the bottom of the piece you'll find
out that Obama's staff ordered those
curtains for 52 K the most expensive
drapery since Joe Biden's hair plugs
there are other examples the recent
anonymous op-ed about insiders trying to
stop Trump that could be inducted into
the fake news Hall of Fame or what I
call CNN I kid him not really I don't
know fact is real non fake news means
nothing to The Times because to them
it's whatever contradicts their wacky
Left worldview remember their idea of a
big thinker and the Times endorsed him
what a member of the house of the house
a member of the house what do you people
like clapping about sick sick people
plus when Republicans are in charge the
son can't possibly shine so it's a snow
pea enrolled is built in chaos must rain
the media Research Center compiled words
the press uses to describe Trump he's
always angry furious outraged infuriated
livid erupting laughing out on a tirade
the good news he only stabbed Mike Pence
twice could have been worse so why this
language well to make you think the
guy's unstable that's today's narrative
unstable next week it'll be living in a
stable with a beautiful mayor don't
question lifestyles absent any harmful
deeds by Trump and faced with great
economic news the media must create a
daily fear that justifies their
sweat-stained night terrors I mean how
dare you not freak out like the times
like the view like CNN to them Trump's
tweets they're like spiders yet you
because you don't read The Times you
sleep through the night like a baby on
dry sheets
unlike Krugman but if you can't live in
fear like them maybe you need a drug
I'll tell you something things are going
great I got a new job and a bonus my
taxes are down and my neighborhoods safe
and clean I tell you something I sleep
well at night bummer isn't it huh you're
doing it all wrong in today's world it's
simply unhealthy if you're not as
stressed out as the media wants you to
be if you're not up all night worrying
about your problems then the problem is
you you need to worry about things even
if they don't exist how do I do that
it's called drama queen it's the first
drug that creates daily stress by
changing the chemical makeup of your
brain designed specifically to wake you
up at 3:00 a.m. and keep you alert for
three solid hours worrying about
ridiculous things the secret ingredient
bad cocaine wait what don't worry I've
already put some in your drink so you'll
feel it by the time you get home
what are we gonna do about our horse it
eats so much hay so much hay never
enough hay we don't have a horse
Larry but what if we did what if we did
we live in a studio apartment in Midtown
what if we moved to a farm and now we
need a horse and it would eat Hank so
much hay never enough hay you are an
idiot
I'm leaving you so how do you feel Larry
awful I was up half the night I feel
terrible the horses right excellent see
in two weeks
so get drama-queen today or don't go on
with your life without worrying so much
[Applause]
he produces more laughs in my hyena
feather tickler I don't like that TV
writer/producer Rob long I wrote that
horrible introduction
she's so sharp she's often mistaken for
cheese I know I wrote that to her new
book hashtag do not disturb is out
October 9th author and TV host Jedediah
bila she'll make you laugh and cry and
then very depressed National Review
reporter cat Tim
he bruised his knee on Mount Rushmore
former WWE Superstar my massive sidekick
Tyrus
Rob what do you make of the the media
crowdsourcing to help bolster their idea
of fake news I mean they did this with
Sarah Palin's emails remember that yeah
but it's such a weird thing cuz they're
already doing that it's like it it feels
to me like Nick confessed sort of
confess are a the guy I feel like he
needs probably to have a little talk
with the whoever that is the HR at
mental health yes person at the new
times because you're not supposed to let
the the wires show yeah this looks like
they're like letting us already know
their playbook which is to sort of find
stuff and then didn't it's fake news
yeah that's true that's very transparent
of them they should be sitting around
going let's find and also like they keep
saying whenever they make mistake it's
like well we don't have enough editors I
guarantee you in the New York Times
building there are enough editors yes
exactly just that they're all partisan
Democrats yeah and they're cash-strapped
so they need this they need crowd to
help them do this I think the real
crowdsource seeing Jedidiah are the
people that force them to do Corrections
once when they saw the nikki Haley that
was real crowdsourcing everybody because
if nobody like if Fox News had just said
what you did to nikki Haley was terrible
they would just say that's Fox News just
retracted that that was yeah well they
did these rights how long does it take
it when they do these little Corrections
that nobody reads in fine print I'm just
curious what's disinformation they say
they're going on is disinformation
campaign try to find all the
misinformation out there
what is misinformation to the New York
Times seriously they're gonna be looking
at people's Facebook posts in their
Facebook groups if I had a Facebook post
out that was talking about Hillary
Clinton the liar in the last election
they would call that misinformation
right I would call that the truth
because she's a liar
you're gonna see a list of items from
the Daily Caller Town Hall foxnews.com
conservative pundits and they're going
to call that misinformation when in fact
those are a lot of the people that are
fact-checking the New York Times you
know you should write a book on Hillary
Clinton and it's called Miss information
with these ideas almost monthly already
titled my next book don't say oh no I
did that I came up with a book a
nutrition book called the Jeddah diet
he's got to say it thank you and cat
I've come up with a lot of titles for
your podcasts none of which are
printable anyway cat it's your opinion
swayed very much by media spin no no
that's good it's gonna be interesting to
see how this plays out because I wonder
if they will just cover the fake news
that hurts Democrats rather than also
covering the fake news that might go
against President Trump because if you
really care about fake news and that's
your issue then you have to cover both
right also I think that this is making
the assumption this entire thing is
making the assumption that fake news is
the reason why Trump won the election
right that's a lot of liberals think
they're going to be very disappointed
when they find out that's not the case
they Trump won the election because
Hillary Clinton was a nightmare of a
candidate it really was that simple
I'm beginning to believe
knocking Hilary we'll get applause I
didn't even know her
I didn't even knock her Tyrus I just
said maybe if I knock her it was a pre
knock it was a pre knock
I had a pre knock agreement once that it
didn't work out Trump administration has
rattled the media in such a good way in
some ways right that they're doing this
I well I would say that keep them honest
with you no that's not happening
yeah I think it's gotten to the point
where this was a board meeting you know
this was a meeting this was a group yes
five or six editors like Johnson what do
you got yeah Russ is not working yeah
he's an adulteress not working he's
lying is not working he's rude not
working what do you got it's quick
something let's go to the people maybe
there's some really good liars in the
street that having some really good
story I saw some stuff on Facebook we
could do that and that's basically it's
like that's our new campaign yeah it's
not us it's the people so now they're
trying to blame it on us yeah because
the fight that they're having is failing
miserably it hasn't really no no one has
seen a story about Trump from his side
it's been like you have wow wow you know
what thank you I didn't know that yeah
yeah the hell with this guy now it's
like you it just gets worse for them you
know what the thing is all the stories
begin with the bad stories with well he
said this nobody cares about what he
said anymore it's whether he's done
stuff and so far what he's done is
fairly rarely productive so no when he
says well did you hear what he said it's
like yeah that's like it's like talking
yeah I take cabs yeah I heard what he
said
but I was busy buying my new boat with
my extra tax money I really don't care
what he's gonna say because I'll be on
my boat
and there's no reception on my brand-new
boat who's thought of that that I paid
cash for summing up immediate the media
is now like I don't remember Three
Stooges there was always one lady and
Three Stooges that was constantly
freaking out like oh that's the media
yeah their immediate still lady from
Three Stooges or actually the Marx
Brothers more about Du Monde yes I'm
sorry you know what I gotta confuse ya
Margaret Dumont is the one see that's
why you're in TV some weirdo that's not
the only reason so true